une belle grosse heure pour aller
chercher des acteurs qui vont
s'impliquer dans son entreprise qui vont
aider à croître
l'un des enjeux de cette campagne est
assurément la création d'emplois un
problème que ne connaît pas la ville de
québec la capitale se retrouve en effet
dans une situation enviable le taux de
chômage est très bas et la ville connaît
depuis une dizaine d'années une
croissance spectaculaire l'une des plus
fortes au canada
alors y at il des leçons à tirer pour
nos politiciens en campagne
sophie langlois et le réalisateur éric
barbeau nous présente cette réussite
économique
québec c'est encore et toujours cette
ville aux décors spectaculaires qui
charment plus de 4 millions de touristes
par année bien divisional se sont tenus
debout crise assure la conquête du mans
québec est une région très très très
compétitif
c'est aussi une capitale qui attire de
plus en plus d'investissements et de
travailleurs étrangers
la région compte maintenant 150 de
filiales de sociétés internationales
on attend sur le portail
c'est le jouet président je vais silva
morais il dirige une entreprise fondée
il ya 14 ans dans un local miteux de la
basse-ville d'inox fut achetée en 2005
par l'américaine d'activision le numéro
un mondial du jeu vidéo
on n'a qu'à saint joseph au cours des
années on s'est vraiment beaucoup
développée maintenant on est plus de 300
employés dans nos nouveaux locaux sur
cholet le quartier saint roch a
littéralement ressuscité des facultés
universitaires et des entreprises de
pointe s'y sont installés attirés par
des loyers subventionnés
le secteur des jeux vidéo embauchent
plus de 1000 personnes
30% des salaires sont encore payés par
l'état
les subventions nous ont aidés à prendre
beaucoup de croissance au départ ont
certainement joué un rôle important avec
le fait qu'on soit qu'on soit établie à
saint roch
le fondateur et ancien président de
beenox a depuis quitté la basse ville et
le monde des jeux vidéo pour celui du
chocolat
moi je veux vraiment conquérir le monde
c'est vraiment un concept chocolats
favoris et unique depuis qu'il a acheté
l'entreprise en 2012
dominique brown a ouvert une quatrième
boutique doubler le chiffre d'affaires
et le nombre d'employés
tout cela avec l'aide d'une nouvelle
fond du pot limit donc on prend ça on
met ça dans l'eau bouillante pendant 20
minutes on sort on aurait avec le clip
on le met dans le milieu de la table et
là ça reste cependant au-dessus d'une
heure dominique brown embauche de 150 à
250 personnes selon les saisons
ce chiffre va continuer d'exploser avec
l'ouverture de trois nouvelles boutiques
en mai et la vente éventuelle de ces
fondus en épicerie les politiques de
diversification économique ont porté
fruits ici des centaines de pme
contribuent à faire baisser le taux de
chômage à 4,1 pour cent
le deuxième plus bas au canada c'est une
situation de plein emploi le taux de
chômage est quasi aussi fait que celui
cadbury alors qu'eux-mêmes patronale
jean québec dont à besoin dit long que
ici la récession pour vraiment frappé la
région
l'industrie des assurances et des
finances mène le bal de la création
d'emplois dans la région qui compte dix
sièges sociaux de compagnies d'assurance
plus de 2000 emplois ont été créés dans
le secteur depuis cinq ans ce
partenariat au lot entre l'université
laval et les besoins du secteur privé
notamment en main d'oeuvre donc sur sa
description gable la performance la
région québec dans les cinq à dix
prochaines dernières années donc ici
cellino l'institut national d'optique il
le parc technologique de québec est un
exemple puissant de cette relation
fructueuse entre l'université laval et
le secteur privé
ici des chercheurs deviennent
entrepreneurs avec l'aide de l'état la
compagnie terre accents par exemple qui
est né dans nos locaux ici avec un seul
individu bon aujourd'hui quand gauche et
au delà de 200 personnes rayonne dans
une cinquantaine de pays
donc je pense que des sociétés comme
celle là qui ont eu des banques pour ce
bon moment pour assurer leur croissance
c'est locle et hop je joue un rôle
important depuis dix ans le nombre
d'emplois dans une centaine
d'entreprises du parc technologique a
doublé pour atteindre 5200 ya eu des
décisions historiques de prise
très audacieuse il ya 25 ans de parler
d'eux par technologique d'une économie
du savoir c'était particulièrement
audacieux pour maintenir l'élan
économique de la région de québec
qu'elle serait aujourd'hui un engagement
politique audacieux d'ajouter un profil
entrepreneurial à l'école un peu comme
on peut dire on peut dire on peut s'en
aller dans une concentration sport
études mais pourquoi pas entrepreneuriat
étudiant nous les impôts afin de faire
plus que l'économie on investit déjà
beaucoup en éducation
mais faut toujours investir davantage
pour que pendant tant qu'on marche jean
nadeau qui court à côté de nous autres
continuons de cheminer sur la voie du
succès le succès du québec c'est tout
c'est une cohésion remarquable entre les
forces économiques et politiques
tout le monde parle d'une seule voix
face à ottawa et à québec pour pousser
des projets comme celui de
l'amphithéâtre le maire la bombe ce juge
tellement choyée qu'il s'est dit gêné
d'en demander plus aux politiciens tels
que j'ai en effet combattants dans un
projet en ce début de campagne
électorale